the war in Yemen is a few years shy of a
decade
an internal conflict that intensified
when Saudi Arabia invaded
now the richest Gulf Arab country wants
out of a war had started with some of
the poorest in the world
yemenis rallying and Sana are clear
about the way forward
they should leave Yemen alone we will
maintain our resistance against the
occupation against the stealing of
yemeni's people's wealth and against the
removal of our decision-making and
Independence
dialogue in a U.N broker truce enabled
the longest period of relative calm in
the eight year long War
but it lapsed in October and after so
much Bloodshed long-term peace seems Out
Of Reach
we are ready to confront the Saudis by
air sea and land the next war will not
be like the previous ones because our
military has developed and advanced
Riyadh set out to reinstate a pro-saudi
yemeni government as it switches Focus
to ambitious economic projects back home
in Yemen tens of thousands of people
have been killed the economy is in Ruins
and millions are being pushed closer to
starvation every day Aid groups point to
the Kingdom's restrictions on the entry
of commercial and humanitarian Goods as
a leading driver of worsening conditions
advised the Saudi rulers to stop
supporting those that have been
financing for the past 60 years because
it will not help them the ones who will
make real peace are the ones they're
fighting so advise them to reach out to
the houthi leader and reach an agreement
with him the conflict is widely seen as
a proxy war between Saudi Arabia and
Iran it's hoped in agreement to restore
diplomatic relations brokered by China
earlier this month will bring an end to
the war Zain basavi Al Jazeera